a partire dal mese di gennaio la nostra
vita in italia altrove è cambiata
radicalmente
non abbiamo bisogno di riandare a tutte
le tappe di questo cambiamento che ha
significato passare da una condizione di
normale ordinaria vita quotidiana ad una
condizione prima di attenzione di timore
di controllo e poi di chiusura radicale
questo in tutta italia a partire dalle 8
e 9 marzo fino quasi alla fine di maggio
ora ci troviamo di fronte ad una
situazione che non è per nulla
migliorata certo mitigata perché le
istituzioni ospedaliere le strutture
ospedaliere sono molto più capaci di
prima di affrontare questo virus che
resta ancora un'incognita in molte parti
del pianeta e per noi stessi e tuttavia
ci dobbiamo rendere conto che fino a
quando non si scopre il virus e non
viene prodotto in quantità
straordinariamente grandi e diffuso a
tutti gli abitanti del pianeta il nostro
problema non sarà risolto quindi
da gennaio è senz'altro da marzo noi in
italia e altri paesi nel mondo
sappiamo una cosa molto chiara ovvero
che la inter relazione tra i popoli del
mondo tra le persone per ragioni
economiche di mercato culturali
semplicemente turistiche di viaggio le
nostre interazioni fanno sì che il
nostro pianeta sia un villaggio ovvero
che tutti noi possiamo contrarre il
virus appunto perché nessuno di noi è
chiuso nella propria terra nella propria
casa nella propria città o nel proprio
villaggio al punto del 9 raccontate con
nessun altro questo rende difficilissimo
interagire e anche difficile da gestire
una condizione che
comunque deve essere gestita quindi la
pandemia da cove 19 ha messo in evidenza
un elemento importante dei nostri tempi
ovvero non si può pretendere
l'isolamento di ciascuno di noi per
impedire la immunità
non si può quindi prevedere o anzi
desiderare o anzi pianificare una
perfetta immunità occorre prevedere un
certo rischio comunque questo nella vita
ordinaria di sempre siamo esseri umani
non siamo di vini
quindi non è il problema di non è di
essere perfettamente immuni problema è
di controllare il livello di
immunizzazione e fare in modo che sia
più ampio possibile affinché ciascuno di
noi possa sentirsi se non perfettamente
sicuro non lo siamo mai perfettamente
sicuri ma certamente diciamo in
condizioni di operare fare scelte
costruire la nostra vita come sempre
ora per far questo finora abbiamo avuto
stati regole norme organizzazioni locali
nazionali internazionali globali che
hanno in qualche modo
assistito la nostra libertà di
organizzazione della vita e hanno
sostenuto le nostre scelte
il codec la pandemia da cover 19 ha
messo in evidenza che questo modo di
operare non è più da solo sufficiente
che occorre un livello superiore o
diciamo globale che sia in grado di non
solo monitorare questi livelli sanitari
di di contagio a cui noi a questo siamo
che stiamo vivendo in questo momento ma
anche sapere governare o può mettere
regole che siano stringenti alle quali
tutti i paesi e quindi tutte le società
debbano alle quali debbano corrispondere
adeguarsi
quindi la pandemia appunto perché non
conosce confini e nemmeno giurisdizioni
di stati con il problema di un governo
globale di un governo di pianeta e il
tema della sanità e della salute legato
alla eccezionalità di questo co.brin si
lega ad un altro problema interrelato
che quello climatico
lo leggiamo praticamente ogni giorno sui
quotidiani
lo vediamo e lo subiamo nelle
trasformazioni dei nostri territori
soprattutto in questa stagione autunnale
vediamo il crollo di ponti e la
distruzione sistematica di di territorio
di vita ordinaria e vediamo come quindi
tutta la nostra vita sia
fondamentalmente esposta a questi due
grossi temi che sono ben al di là dei
confini nazionali
quello della salute o quindi della
protezione
da contagio e quindi un livello un grado
di immunità che sia compatibile con la
nostra capacità di decisione di libertà
e il la protezione delle condizioni
basilari di vita sul pianeta ovvero la
questione climatica sono due temi che
nessun paese può pretendere da solo di
risolvere e nemmeno di mettere a in
sicurezza sono due temi che ci impongono
impongono a tutto il pianeta di prendere
decisioni molto importanti e di grande
responsabilità sulla presente e che è
avvenuto sul futuro quindi se
l'organizzazione mondiale della sanità
deve riorganizzare o diciamo rivedere il
suo protocolli suoi protocolli di
intervento le sue normative non lo deve
fare insieme ai governi ed insieme alla
all'organizzazione mondiale all'onu per
poter avere un impatto diretto per poter
aiutare e sostenere i paesi
quindi non solo monitorando non solo
ponendo regole molto stringenti sul modo
di operare dei popoli della terra
affinché non ci siano o siano
minimizzate le condizioni di contagio e
quindi della produzione
all'organizzazione alimentare con regole
che vadano rispettate e monitorate
dovunque sul nostro pianeta
quindi controllare il commercio e fare
in modo che la salute sia un bene sul
quale non ci sia possibilità o
giustificazione per di violazioni in
nome di altri interessi siano essi
economici o politici
e quindi avere un autorevolezza questo
da parte dell'organizzazione mondiale
della sanità diciamo non soltanto di
impegno e di diciamo controllo e di
monitoraggio ma anche la capacità di
imporre una serie di modelli di
comportamento e indurre gli stati tutti
gli stati se non altro quelli che sono
parte delle organizzazioni dell'onu
tutti gli stati che accettino di
condividere e di mettere in atto queste
norme per la sicurezza la stessa cosa
deve succedere deve essere fatta con il
clima noi abbiamo bisogno di
un'organizzazione mondiale che faccia lo
stesso servizio della e anzi meglio
forse dell'organizzazione mondiale della
sanità in relazione alla questione
climatica
non è possibile che paesi come gli stati
uniti o il brasile o la cina o la russia
possano pensare che il loro territorio
sia esclusivamente loro proprietà la
terra è proprietà dell'umanità viene
gestita dai singoli stati ma non è di
proprietà dei singoli stati per una
ragione anche semplice poiché quello che
viene fatto quello che viene prodotto
quello che viene manomesso in un area
come queste del brasile degli stati
uniti o della russia della cina ha un
impatto diretto su tutti gli altri
abitanti del pianeta quindi ci deve
interessare come la cina come gli stati
uniti come il brasile come la russia
governano il loro territorio perché il
modo di governare il loro territorio ha
un impatto sulla nostra vita qua quindi
è fondamentale comprendere che non
possiamo più permetterci il lusso di
restare indifferenti a quello che gli
altri fanno ea quello che non fa